alors les chéris je suis tombé sur un
sondage arômes bien sûr un sondage qui
est complètement fou assez incroyable ce
week-end vous allez jouer pour retrouver
le sujet de ce sondage 35% des couples
mettent six mois à le faire de quoi
s'agit-il
se fâcher avec sa belle-mère 35 fonction
des coupes maximois le faire deux
conseillers de se fâcher que ça te fait
chier avec ça le fait rire illégaux tels
à 10 au cosec s'appelle berry est
content kelly oui à faire l'amour à le
faire voir nancy 6 heures 6 minutes 6
minutes à le faire médaille voire au
naturel assure maquiller à maquiller ou
pas après tout ça à maquiller tout ça
non ce n'est pas ça 35% des coûts de le
mettre six mois à le faire à votre avis
de quoi il s'agit oui la belle route et
non mais à une autre commence pas
possible non mais on est très à l'aise
mais c'est toujours la personne on s'y
attend le moins
côté complètement taré toi bien que
sachant que cette aubaine alors attendez
attendez eric à sortir l'un sans l'autre
à sortir d'un solo c'est à dire que oui
mais tu sors avec ses copains seul met
six mois à sortir l'un sans l'autre
c'est eric naulleau très mauvaise
réponse non non géré a dit me faire
l'amour avec la lumière allumée away
sinois faire l'amour avec la lumière à
lui est en effet la seule à moi à l'aise
avec la lumière à lui jean michel aulas
est même de lumière au bout
des projets poursuit yann poursuites
maintenant la catalina toujours
l'impression d'être dans le droit chemin
mais si elle fait l'amour avec la
lumière allumée samarie qui ne fait que
lumière éteinte obligatoirement on n'a
pas dit qu'il ne fait pas vous un peu
sombre un peu sombre pour des raisons
sur la tamise la tamise d'accord allez
bonne nuit fais d'abord exclusivement
alors à temps alors 35 % des couples
mettent six mois à le faire de quoi
s'agit-il jean michel baylet rond sans
lozeau aller ensemble aux autres
réponses allez on prend là des signaux
seriez allé aujourd'hui à les états
n'ont pas de valhalla faudra cette
partie non ils ont changé les skis bars
et les chaussettes quoi échanger les
sites les chaussées oui vous avez déjà
échangé des slips avec votre avec moi
qu'avec la wii ou quoi bien sûr il fait
qu'il fait qu'elle tags skinhead
il m'était slip quoi ils rentrer dans
vos films et la pluie cette dernière
[Applaudissements]
oui à rencontrer les beaux parents mais
c'est moi rencontrer les baupin voilà la
sagesse 35% des comptes remettre six
mois à le faire ça n'est pas du tout la
bonne réponse
restait pour partie fait un peu âmes à
laymont à faire l'amour sans préservatif
non c'est pas ça on rappelle à tous les
jeunes qui nous regardent faut se
protéger les chéris alors qu'ils n'ont
les deux cépages laissons pas voir toi
moi c'est françois vo faire l'amour en
pyjama faire quel est le risque
non mais tu crois vraiment que des mecs
à leschères elhadj aura la foule ça fait
six mois qu'on lance en lancement puis
jamais fait l'amour je vois c'est bon la
flight écoyeux jusque là quoi non mais
c'est un pari ce matin à faire l'amour
devant la télévision allumée
le vent de quoi j'me mêle fait peur à la
halle avec eric naulleau très stimulant
pour la vie sexuelle des couples et
malheureusement ce n'est pas la bonne
réponse se dire à quoi à chaque fois qu
à chaque fois qu a fait une intervention
à se gratter les papilles à roter quoi
la ville est son métier ribes
ce regret même invité jamais chez vous j
aurais tu là c'est incroyable dit il
dix clubs alors tout à l'heure ça va
être quoi tout à l'heure ça va être quoi
si vous continuez
oui c'était autre chose mais c'est quoi
alors attendez tout au bout de 6 mois
donc votre maître se gratter les parties
et rod et voilà c'est à dire qu'on est
plus on est moins attentionné mois à
temps et au bout de huit mois c'est quoi
faire clic à la porte ouverte
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas alors là ça c'est au bout de
combien de langues
mettez-y pour les arts en général au
bout de huit mois et après et au bout
d'un an est ce pas c'est quoi alors
après mes fichiers sur la table c'est
moi sur le lit tranquille mais
tranquilles ou à tranquille où le mec
l'arrivée merci c'est bon allez on y va
on remballe tout mais c'est exceptionnel
alors à quoi on est maintenant au bout
de quarante deux ans qu'est ce qui se
passe maintenant après ça se normalise
sur la table à toulouse
c'était aux lois c'est bon tu la ramènes
c'est ma femme et moi dyson là chez aaa
mais c'est bon quoi
alors attention oui attendait non merci
ou que j'avais une question pour un
minois alors c'est vrai qu'on est dans
le sondage bourse ou redécouvrir le
maître six mois le faire de quoi
s'agit-il faut se poser d'abord votre
question parce que j'ai une copine qu'il
le fait s'appelle charline j'embrasse
est-ce que tu t'assois sur les genoux
mari quand tu vas à l'appel et si le vol
est pourquoi elle le fait pas non on est
quoi y'a une copine à vous qu'on fait ça
lui soit relâché à l'ébauché contre une
et vous quel âge à l'époque il avait 18
denham ils font les dons même temps
d'autres légendes aux ménages
battus par lyon
ont vaincu leurs chars vous allez voir
que nous faire c'est génial c'est
charlie avec son mec sergei et bagarres
des affaires cac à califourchon ses
filiales les nommer alors attention les
chéris h 30 ça pour cent des couples
osent le faire au bout de six mois
m 6 mois à le faire s'est même pas
odeurs 35 % des couples maximois à le
faire de quoi s'agit-il
se dire se dire je te dire non se dire
oh là là là le vrai nombre de
partenaires qu'on a eue avant on va en
demandent toujours à oui oui on dit
toujours moins que ce qu'on a vraiment
eu quoi vous dites genre par exemple
vous avez dit - apatow je vous ai dit
quoi j'ai dit combien taiwan à 3 donc
ces trois ont peu moins de 3 votre
ex-mari patoche et un l'autre et le prof
de ski une petite semaine valérie bénaïm
a alors c'est vrai qu'on monte toujours
sur sa 35 % des couples mettent six mois
le faire de quoi s'agit-il valérie
benaïm vous avez dit à dire le nombre de
partenaires qu'on a eue avant avant le
bon avoir le bon et bien valérie bénaïm
une fois de plus vous êtes à côté de la
plaque la réponse je vous la donne dans
un instant à tout de suite au tivoli 35%
des coupes à la mettre six mois le faire
de quoi s'agit-il
alors eh bien je vais vous le dire vous
avez été beaucoup à réagir sur twitter
nous dire que ce qu'au fond les couples
est bien celle qui était le plus proche
sachez que c'était isabelle et oui 35 %
des couples et c'est un sondage qui est
sorti ce matin dans une étude très
sérieuse
35% des coupes mettre six mois a osé
péter devant l'autre
ouais j'avais la moyenne nadal avait
jeudi à vannes 2 % le font après un mois
et 10 % et pour cent des couples se pète
dessus immédiat et d'avoir appris à se
connaître
ce n'est pas une bonne selon l' enquête
dans un coup le premier vent arrive
quasiment au même moment où les amoureux
se disent le premier je t'aime
non mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
mais voilà et apparemment beaux-arts
magazine tombe très vite amoureuse mais
je vous jure que c'est vrai nous repérer
les plaidoiries des mecs sont payés au
cdrs pour savoir bout de combien de
temps les gens se paie tonnacquois même
et je vous dire que ça m'arrive
attendait c'est un sondage ça etc ou
dessin très important voilà vous
confirmez oui oui vous confirmez vous
alors on va on va parler à la
spécialiste confirmé puisqu'on en est
aux confessions intimes totalement in no
2 rangs n'ont pas même quand il peu de
chance on dirait que cela ton mari - un
tir etc sonatu marie qua non mais 65
cents pas façon absolument pas en tout
cas c'est une très belle un fond c'est
important d'avoir cette info aujourd'hui
week-end il faut pas rigoler il faut
juste s'y enfin signalé que ce sondage
est super important parce que dans tous
les cas ce qu'il s'agit de péter ou
dorothée et à un moment donné pour le
corps et l'esprit c'est une des choses
les plus importantes pour ses auteurs
d'un rapport
oui mais il faut de la tv magazine de la
santé un nom mais il est mal à écouter
bon tout ça valait ray lane arfa ne nous
disaient que ça pète et des coûts dans
les cours de yoga
ah oui c'est vrai oui cela libère les
chakras libère des shows crabe à écouter
ballet chacun arrivera d'ici là il s'est
pas déjà cédé horde de chacun